So we've been covering and talking about
these tragic major mass shootings over the
last week in the United States. One of them
took place in Colorado. And as if we needed
any kind of reminder about the pernicious
and depraved nature of the NRA,
the National Rifle Association consider
that the NRA bragged that it helped
block a ban on R 15s and high capacity magazines
in Boulder, Colorado, just days before a shooter
with exactly that type of firearm killed
10 people in Boulder at a grocery store.
Think about that, the NRA bragging about that
and after the shooting, the NRA actually tweeted
a defense of the Second Amendment, if you can
imagine anything more crass and poorly timed,
although maybe for them it's exactly the
right time to tweet this stuff, saying, quote,
a well regulated militia being necessary to
the security of a free state, the right of
the people to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed. They are bragging about their role
in blocking a Boulder, Colorado, ban on the exact
type of weapon that six days later was used for
the shooting. And the NRA tweeted about a decision
made in Boulder, quote, A Colorado judge gave law
abiding gun owners something to celebrate.
He ruled that the city of Boulder is ban
on commonly used R 15s and ten plus round
magazines was preempted by state law and struck
them down. This was a ban passed by the Boulder
City Council unanimously. In twenty eighteen. They
passed in twenty eighteen, an assault weapons
ban and a high capacity magazine ban after
the Marjorie Stoneman Douglas school shooting in
Parkland, Florida. It has gone through appeals and
this fight and now the NRA celebrates, we got them
back, the AR 15s. And then six days later, one is
used in Boulder, Colorado, to kill ten people.
And what we have to remember and understand is,
I mean, listen, first of all, there is no more
depraved and backwards organization in the US
than the National Rifle Association, maybe
the Republican Party, but one of the most
depraved and backwards organizations. But you
have to understand that the NRA is a business
lobby. OK, the WHO are the customers of the
NRA? It's not the gun owners. It's the gun
manufacturers. And the gun manufacturers make
money by selling guns. Democratic presidents
help to sell guns because the NRA will claim that
these Democrats are going to come and take your
guns under Barack Obama, under the threats from
the NRA, under the announcements from the NRA
that Barack Obama was a threat to gun ownership.
We saw record gun sales under Donald Trump,
who was not caricatured as the president that
will take your guns. Gun sales actually declined.
The other aspect of this, and this is, you know,
it's just a reality. Mass shootings also sell
guns for two reasons. Number one, the NRA comes
in and says, look at how dangerous the world is
out there, partially because the NRA has been
so successful. It's really dangerous out there.
You need guns. And then so people go and then
they buy more guns. And then, of course, mass
shootings also sell guns, because after the mass
shooting, groups like the NRA and other gun rights
groups will say this is not the time for Democrats
to come take your guns, which they want to do,
which perpetuates people wanting to go and
stockpile even more firearms and ammunition.
So as I said earlier today, we have a Second
Amendment. I don't dispute that my left leaning
gun owning friends don't dispute that. Many of
us on the left have actually armed ourselves
during the pandemic, partially for fears
that, you know, if these supply lines for
toilet paper, but maybe more critically, other
other items, medical elements, food, whatever,
if if the supply lines are interrupted for
longer periods of time, many on the left saying,
I don't want the right wingers to be the only
ones with the firearm. So this is not about
contesting that there's a Second Amendment
or whatever. This is about the pernicious
and depraved nature of groups like the NRA, whose
answer is always more guns. Their primary thing is
let's prevent bans on any types of firearms and
then they're secondary. Thing is, if it's safe out
there, we say it's safe because of guns. If it's
dangerous out there, we say, well, you need more
guns. If there's a Democratic president, they're
coming for your guns, so you should get them. Now,
the answer is always more guns for the
NRA. And it's hard to imagine at this point
a more immoral organization. There probably
are some, but I'm struggling to think of them.